hi everyone i'm mark hamilton and i'm a
research development engineer on the
microsoft cognitive services research
team
and i'm also a phd student in william
freeman's lab at mit
today i want to share a project with you
for deep
interpretable visual analogies this work
is kind of designed to find
connections across culture and media in
the fine arts
there's a bit of a backstory about this
project the kind of inspiration for this
algorithm came from a trip to the
reich's museum
there they had an exhibit called
rembrandt and velazquez
that took works from rembrandt and his
collaborators and put them in dialogue
with works from the great spanish master
velasquez
and although these painters and their
studios didn't have any contact
and worked at opposite ends of europe
they still
painted incredibly similar scenes that
really
spoke to a deeper connection in
the content and the semantics of these
works and so two that i found really
impactful
were um this two juxtapositions on the
martyrdom
of saint serapion and the threatened
swan and although these
are two very different subject matters
they still convey the same core
idea you know on the left here um we
have
uh saint serapion dying for our sins
with his arms outstretched in a
defensive and yet surrendering pose and
on the right we have the threatened swan
again with wings outstretched protecting
her nest
from an unforeseen enemy and so although
these two works are incredibly different
they still speak to something very
similar that both of these artists are
trying to get at
in their representation and so we
thought that this exhibit was really
impactful and got everyone
very excited about the connections
between art we were wondering if an
algorithm could potentially
scale this out and find connections not
just between rembrandt and velazquez
but between any artist or culture or
media
across time periods and really in a much
more rigorous sense
so to formalize this notion we realize
that this
algorithm would need to find visual
analogies in the collection
if you kind of think about it martyrdom
i'm saying sarah pion
and the threatened swan are almost in
analogy
spanish is to dutch as martyrdom is to
the threatened swan
and so to create an algorithm to kind of
find these close matches we need to do
something a little bit like this
and this particular structure appears in
a variety of different places in the
machine learning literature
and perhaps the one that most people are
familiar with
is how it appears in text so here i'll
present a simple
an algorithm for textual analogies and
um we'll see you know what aspects of it
are similar to this problem what aspects
are a little bit different
the basic gist of this method is that
you take
a large corpus of words and you want to
learn a representation for each word
such that the core
ideas and semantics are reduced down
into a very small
tight representation called a feature so
the way you do this is that you play a
little game
and the basic gist of the intuition
behind this game is that
a word gets its meaning from the company
it keeps
aka a word's definition is in some sense
uh
learnable by looking at its surrounding
words
and so in this case the the algorithm
tries to learn
representations for words such that you
can take a word
and predict its surrounding context so
in this case we want to learn
a function that goes from king to all
the words that surround king like the
noble sat
on his throne and this function is
parameterized
and when we learn this function we learn
representations for each one of the
words that make up this sentence and
what's amazing is that these
representations are useful for
a variety of downstream tasks and they
also have a lot of hidden properties
that people were really stunned when
they discovered
in particular they can answer the
analogy question and so for example if
you had an analogy like man as to woman
as king
is to something what you can do is find
the embeddings for man and woman
look at their difference and then apply
that difference to the king
in bedding and when you find the closest
word that comes out you find that it is
the answer to this analogy
namely queen so already
we can kind of see that these
intelligent embeddings sort of
are able to get us close to this
solution and the only problem
is that in the visual domain we don't
really have known
pairs like man and woman we've really
used our
intuition and our knowledge of english
to be able to find this gender
direction but in the corpus of the
metropolitan museum of the reichs museum
we don't really have these pairs a
priori and so we need to use a slightly
different method
so this method will involve a few new
pieces of machinery that will hopefully
be able to explore so as a bit of an
overview of what we'll be discussing
today
we'll first discuss some of the building
blocks of this algorithm
namely deep image retrieval and we'll
figure out how to specialize this system
using a technique called conditional
nearest neighbor methods
finally we'll evaluate this kind of
approach
using non-parametric style transfer
then we'll see that we don't just want
to
find these close matches and analogies
in the collection
we often want to understand why these
particular systems are working the way
that they're working
what is it that the algorithm is picking
up on that
makes this particular kind of visual
analogy so we'll explore how we can
dive into the algorithm's brain and
figure out a little bit more about
what's going on
underneath finally we'll give you a
little research snack
and apply this algorithm to something
completely out of left field
namely finding blind spots in generative
adversarial networks
these particular spots are areas where
gans just fail to create data
you've seen these incredibly stunning
images of human faces and we'll see
where gans
produce significantly less stunning
results
so to understand how we can create a
visual analogy system
we'll have to understand a little bit
about deep image retrieval
the basic idea is that you want to take
an image say your dog
and find the closest or most similar
image within a collection of images like
the metropolitan museum or the reich's
museum
so to do this we can't just compare
distance in pixel space
because that distance isn't very robust
it's very
susceptible to things like small
rotations or changes in brightness
so we can form a much better notion of
distance by first taking this image
and mapping it into deep feature space
the idea behind this is that you take a
big
trained vision network that already
knows how to see
and recognize images quite like a human
being does
and you use the inner activations of
this network as a new space to put your
images in
here distance really corresponds to
similarity as you and i
might think so now that we have a space
where distance is semantically
meaningful
finding the closest images is in some
sense finding the most
related images now using nearest
neighbors
we can find images in the collection
that closely
resemble the image that you fed it the
query image so in this case we get this
nice little egyptian dog from the
metropolitan collection
so this algorithm works pretty nicely
you can kind of take any photo from your
instagram and this is one that we
were working on and find really
interesting artworks that kind of match
what's going on in your life
and even when it doesn't work here's a
two below the cat
we find that the results are kind of
stunning and ridiculous and hilarious
and so although this isn't quite what
you'd expect
you know it's not quite wrong either so
we can kind of see that there is
something going on here it's picking up
not just on the content
not just on the visual aspects but a
little bit of both
and so this particular algorithm is a
really simple way to do deep
image retrieval but it doesn't really
answer our question of
what if we want to find the closest
match by a particular artist
like rembrandt it's difficult to know
where to start to hone into just a
particular class or subset of the
collection
and for that we'll need to develop some
new machinery
in particular what we want to hone in on
is how do we actually
find these k-nearest neighbors and then
we can modify them to restrict their
attention to specific sets of points
the basic gist of efficient k-nearest
neighbors search
can be thought of as taking the space of
points and
partitioning them to form a kind of tree
this tree will make querying much more
efficient
there's a variety of ways to do this
fast nearest neighbor search but we
focus on tree-based methods because
these particular methods have a natural
way to condition
or restrict their attention to subsets
so here i have a query point shown in
red and i have a bunch of points
shown in white and some high dimensional
space these are kind of images the
features
and they're just here represented in two
dimensions
so if you wanted to find the closest
white point to that red point
you wouldn't start all the way at the
bottom of the page you kind of look at
the points that are close to the red
point you'd take a little ball around
the red point and only look in that
space
so this is kind of the intuition for the
algorithm this
is called the ball tree and what it does
is it takes the points and it splits
them up
recursively and draws a ball around
these points
far away balls you're able to prune from
your search because you know that their
every single point within that ball is
just too far away using mathematical
techniques like the triangle inequality
or the koshi schwarz inequality if
you're dealing with inner products
so you can do this recursively each time
finding more and more balls that you're
able to throw away because they don't
contain relevant points
eventually you'll get to a point where
there's a small enough number of points
in your tree that you can actually just
search through them with brute force
search to find the closest point
to your given query point
so as a recap we can take a bunch of
points
and we can recursively split them up
form a tree-like structure of these
balls
and this will help us perform queries
will help us hone in
on the exact neighborhood of our query
point so that we only need to look at a
very small number of points
and save ourselves a lot of time in the
comparison
however the data we have doesn't just
exist in a vacuum
there's a lot more to it than just the
features of the images
for instance we might have labels of
genre or class or medium or
artist so as a stand-in we'll use color
here in this example for a nice
simple example so i've colored these
points in the tree based on
say what genre of art they are
on the right i've colored the leaves of
the tree based on which labels they
contain
so as you can see this coloring of the
points induces a coloring on the nodes
of the tree
now if i want to ask a question like can
you find me the closest blue point
to the given red point i don't need to
search through the entire tree
you can quickly prune most of the nodes
of the tree
and just look at the nodes that have
blue points within them
this is sort of the basis of the
algorithm what we want to do is we want
to take
big k nearest neighbor data structure
and find a way to efficiently prune it
on the fly for any given kind of subset
or class
that we might want to restrict our
search to
the natural question is how do we
actually prune this tree
for this we'll take a page out of an
algorithm called elasticsearch
what elasticsearch does is it's a way to
organize your documents
and make search engines on top of your
documents so say
you have a collection of hard-hitting
news items that you want to be able to
index and pull up based on keywords
which elasticsearch does is it forms
what's called an
inverted index it takes all the words of
the documents
and it maps them to which documents
contain those words
that way when you search for something
like tiger you can immediately using a
hash map get all of the documents that
contain the word tiger
if you wanted something like tiger and
king you can
take these sets of documents and
intersect them to find all the documents
that contain both tiger
and king likewise if you want a tiger or
king you can take
their union so in this case the
logical predicates that you use in
search namely and
or and not they correspond to set
theoretic
intersection and union operations and
this lets you take some complicated
logical query
and really quickly retrieve all of the
documents that satisfy that query that
you gave to the search engine
and so this is on the basis of
technologies like azure search and
google search
and it really helps you pull up large
corpuses of documents incredibly quickly
so in our particular case we don't just
want to filter documents we want to
filter the nodes
of the nearest neighbor tree so in this
case instead of documents we now
think about an inverted index from
conditions or subsets
to the parent nodes of the tree that
remain after pruning
here in this example let's say i want to
restrict my attention to just
yellow nodes i can really quickly get
all of the remaining nodes by using our
inverted index
and see that we have our exact subset of
the tree
ready for querying
so now that we have kind of a method to
modify the k
nearest neighbor data structure to
support conditions or subsets
of the retrieved images we can now swap
out that piece
in our original architecture now
with this new algorithm we can add in
additional types of conditions
here i'll show the closest results for
paintings and ceramics and also cultures
namely japanese culture so as you can
see you can kind of find the closest
match to that given dog but
in each one of these different
conditions and we recently just found
this cute little
japanese netsuke and we were really
excited when we found this little
cute image here
now that we have a method to find us the
nearest neighbors for a particular class
of objects
we can take objects in the collection
and see
what their equivalent objects are in
different cultures and media
so here we have an example where we
start with a ming dynasty
porcelain blue and white vase we can
find its closest
textile in this case we get a
double-faced banyan
from the netherlands and what's more we
can go
and even ask more outlandish question
like what's the closest
musical instrument and when we actually
asked people this without showing them
the answer
they kind of took a look at that photo
and said i don't know maybe a cello
and so we were really excited when we
got a porcelain violin
we didn't even know this was in the
collection
you can clearly see that the shape of it
almost kind of matches the
the bowed out bottom of the dress and
the colors and the texture are almost
identical
and these three things are not
coincidences
they actually are indicative of a much
greater cultural exchange going on
in particular the the dutch frequented
japan and jingdijiang china and took
porcelain and exported it back to europe
and this created sort of a craze for
that
classic blue and white pottery that you
see all over the netherlands
and also all over china so this is
really
a snapshot of a broader intercultural
exchange between the dutch
and the chinese and a variety of
porcelain makers
from around the world
for another example we wanted to see how
different works kind of evolve
throughout time so here what we start
with is a painted panel of tatiase the
figure of reverence
in 800 bc egypt and
we can kind of find its closest match in
the italian collection we find again
a figure of reverence david and you'll
note that they
share a lot of common visual attributes
namely they're symmetric
they're framed by this kind of arch
winding the clock forward a little bit
we can see that the closest chinese
match is this
particular textile of the buddha again
perfectly framed and symmetric with an
arch
and finally the american equivalent of
this particular archetype is george
washington here another figure of
reference
perfectly framed symmetrical so what
this really speaks to
is um that we tend to
design these ornaments of reverence in a
common way
we find symmetry and framing very
important
throughout our culture you know this
isn't just something that happened
in the american revolution it goes all
the way back for the past three
millennia
it kind of speaks to a common thread
that we've all been designing off of
for a very long time
so here is kind of a larger scale of
some of the matches that we found you
can do this with
really any match of the collection so
some of the fun ones that i want to
point out
is uh this particular image over here of
the blue crane in the top left
when you try to constrain its match to
glass you find this crazy looking
drinking glass over here
that's actually called a swan necked
bottle so it takes the
the metaphorical and really makes this
literal
so the goal of this project is not just
to find cross-cultural connections for
ourselves
but to really create a tool such that
art historians and museum goers alike
can explore the collection in new ways
for themselves
on their web browser to this end we take
this research and we've created a
website to help users explore this
we release this today and call this
mosaic you can access it by going to aka
dot ms
mosaic let's check it out
here we have the landing page and we can
see that a random artwork
has been selected from the collection
portion of a girl dressed in blue
and we can see the closest matches in
the ceramics collection
you can filter by various different
cultures
or mediums so here we can take a look at
some of the closest matches in the
japanese collection
or we can find the closest matches and
say the american collection
to find artworks that really have the
same kind of semantics
and for any given work we can kind of
check out the original source at the
metropolitan museum
kind of figure out why these particular
two artworks
matched using shap and um
explore matches for ourselves using this
new artwork
as a particular starting point
and so here we can kind of explore
say closest work of ceramics
in this particular example it's
retrieved an italian ceramic artwork
that has a similar scene of a
variety of people so let's say we wanted
to jump to a completely
random area of the collection we can do
so over here i can search for something
like a turkey
and we can see using azure search
variety of different turkey style images
we can kind of pick one to start our
next
journey with so we can kind of like this
turkey dish
over here
now we can subset based on various
different cultures so we can find the
closest
chinese turkey and we see that it's this
figure of a crow and
with a kind of bright feather
ornamentation
and we can also take a look at various
different mediums here we can see this
uh
this dutch print and we can go to the
underlying source
at the reichs museum at any time to
learn more information about this
particular
work this website was built by a
fabulous team
of mit externs over the course of just
only one month
and so i definitely want to give them a
shout out thank you very much to
stephanie
mindren ben felix darius maggie marina
and johnny for all of your hard work
this past winter
this team really hit the ground running
with
no prior experience in this kind of work
and was able to create
a great website to help explore and make
this research more tangible
so i've shown you how the algorithm
works and some of the results that it
returns
we now want to get a better
understanding of how this algorithm
performs
is it faster than brute force search is
it performant
does it scale to other data sets and so
that's really what we'll tackle in these
next few slides
so the first particular aspect of this
is evaluating the speed
of conditional k nearest neighbors is
this even worth it to go through all
this trouble of modifying the tree and
creating an inverted index
so to kind of quantify this what we want
to do is compare this
pruned tree over here this tree that
we've made on the full data set
but pruned using our inverted index to a
tree that's made specifically
for the task of this individual subset
and i should mention that
this tree on the right will always
perform better you know it doesn't have
to look
through as many points but it takes a
long time to make that tree for every
subset you know it takes
around three orders of magnitude more
than just querying the tree
so it's a very expensive operation that
we hope to avoid
but we hope to really get our
performance as close as possible to this
tree
so here we have a graph of kind of how
this performs as a function of the size
that you'd like to reduce your query
down to so on the x-axis i kind of have
the size of the data set as a percentage
here
over here on the right we have basically
an unconditional
k-nearest neighbor search and over here
on the left we're dealing with one
percent
of the data that you're looking to
restrict your attention to
and these solid lines here when they get
close to their corresponding dotted
lines
this means that the performance of the
conditional solution
matches the performance of these
specific tree
that's built on the subset this green
line here this is representing brute
force queries
so at a high level what you can pull
from this graph is for
larger subsets down to about one percent
this is
much more efficient than brute force
search and also it kind of approaches
the best case scenario
of designing trees for each individual
specific query
however you don't need to incur the
incredibly steep overhead of actually
making all these different trees
you can get this simply by querying an
inverted index
and we put this table up here for
reference you know we've done this on a
lot of different data sets not just the
the mat
and the reichs museum and we find that
this trend holds globally throughout
them and you can definitely check out
the paper that we've attached on the
side
for more information
in addition to understanding how this
algorithm performs in terms of speed
we also wanted to get a handle of how
this algorithm performs in terms of
quality
we wanted to find a way to understand is
there a way to improve this algorithm
and
measure its improvements quantitatively
so my advisor bill he suggested that
what this algorithm is really doing is
it's performing style transfer
in a sense you know when you take the
image of the swan and you
turn it into glass in some sense this is
kind of like applying a style to it
although this style is really
non-parametric it's formed by
taking another image in the actual data
set it's not drawn on or modifying the
original image
it's fully data driven so
to evaluate this method we've created
two new data sets where we know the
content
and the style this way we can perform
conditional image retrieval
across different styles to make sure
that the content
remains the same to help evaluate these
kinds of conditional image retrieval
methods we've released the conditional
art data set
with over 1 million color images 5 000
content from ms coco
and 200 styles from the wiki art data
set
we then take adaptive instance
normalization style transfer
and stylize each content image with the
requisite style from the wiki art data
set
this gets us this huge array of images
where we know the content
and the style of each one so that we can
evaluate
conditional image retrieval methods and
is a human created baseline we have the
conditional font data set
this one uses letters kind of glyphs of
the english language as the content and
fonts is the style so
in order to actually make quantitative
evaluation out of these data sets what
we do is we
pick an image we pick a style and we ask
does finding the k nearest neighbors
conditioned on that style
return us an image with the same content
that we originally picked
if we get if we recover that same
content
then we have a successful algorithm
when we actually perform this analysis
we find that it gets much better than
random
if you were randomly pull images you'd
only hit the right image about
0.002 percent of the time however
if you were to use a conditional image
retrieval method you get the right
answer about 60 percent of the time
which is considerably
above random so we can kind of see that
this is implicitly performing
this non-parametric style transfer and
we also have a way of
evaluating the quality of the embeddings
used in the method
so the images i've shown are from
resnet50 but through this analysis we've
seen that densenet
squeezenet and mask rcnn might provide
better embeddings
for more relevant non-parametric style
transfer
and visual analogy methods
so we've seen how we can find
these kind of visual analogies in the
mets and wright museum
collection but often when we get these
analogies
one one of the things the curators ask
is why are these two images similar
can we actually explain what the
algorithm is doing
underneath the hood so here i have a
query image and a retrieved image
and it's not quite clear what's going on
here you know it might be looking at the
clothes
it might be looking at the arm it might
be looking at the pose of the body the
hair
the head it could really be anything so
what we wanted to do is create an
algorithm that is able to answer that
question of
why did these two images match
so to create this algorithm what we did
is take
tools from the existing model
interpretability of literature
so there's a fairly successful algorithm
called lime
and another algorithm that came after it
called shap
and these tools are really successful in
interpreting image classification or
regression systems
and while we don't quite have a
classification system
um we'll see later how we can kind of
massage it
in order to transform it into a
classifier
so as a brief introduction to model
interpretability we have
here a leopard classifier that is able
to take a photo
and spit out the probability that there
is a leopard in the image
so in this particular example we can
clearly see a leopard and we can clearly
see that if there's a high probability
so what lime does is that it takes this
image and it perturbs it it randomly
turns on and off
splotches of the image and the basic
intuition is that if you happen to turn
off the leopard you should see that your
algorithm
has a dramatic hit on the probability of
there being a leopard
so in this case if we down here in the
bottom sensor the leopard out
the algorithm is no longer going to say
that there's a leopard in there
so from this we can get a rough
understanding of which pixels
groups of pixels are actually important
and
actually contain the leopard we do this
by creating a locally weighted
regression
and looking at the actual weights of
this regression and
when it's all said and done you find
that the the groups of pixels that
correspond to that leopard really light
up
in this uh regression and so these are
the the actual pixels that explain
why this particular classifier spit out
this particular label
so to apply this to our particular
analysis
we can kind of take a step back and draw
this out schematically
we have an image we feed it through a
classifier we get what's called
probability logits and we apply this
model interpretability technique that
randomly
turns on and off pixels or in shap
performs a game theoretic comp
computation
in order to find the pixels that
correspond to our classification
with this approach no matter how you
build your semantic retrieval system
you're able to transform it in such a
way that you can apply
the algorithm lime and chap to it to
understand
why it's viewing two images is similar
really hone in on the pixels that
make these two images similar
so when we go back to our original
example and we apply these kinds of
techniques
we can see some really striking results
namely
on the conditional image that's
constrained to the drawing category
we see that the algorithm is really
picking up on the flowing robes of these
two images
as you can see they're lit up here and
here
say if we have a different conditional
match like this one constrained to lie
in tibetan culture um we were actually
surprised that it
it wasn't looking at the robes so much
as it was looking at the the
shining lake that's kind of in a similar
position in both of these
so this is kind of an example about how
these two different rationales for the
matches can be
disentangled and elucidated by using a
model interpretability framework
so as i mentioned this is kind of a
generic transformation that allows you
to use
anything from the model interpretability
literature
applied to this task of image retrieval
and so we can just take all of these
methods and compare them
here we show this in a chart you can
begin to see that methods like shap
tend to to find more important types of
pixels than than lime
roughly speaking and that's because shap
has a set of formal guarantees that kind
of guarantee
that the interpretation you have is
unique can satisfy
a bunch of nice mathematical conditions
however we wanted to actually understand
which one was better quantitatively
as opposed to just relying on our
qualitative instincts
so to actually evaluate these kinds of
image
retrieval interpretability methods we
play a simple game
we take two images that are really close
together let's say two photos of lex the
pomeranian here
and we see that they're really similar
they're roughly a 95 percent match
say now we interpret this match we're
able to get a heat map
over the pixels where the hottest areas
are the ones that are most important for
the similarity
and you can see that it clusters around
lex's head here
we then censor these most important say
top 20
percent of these pixels we should
dramatically affect the similarity of
these two images
you know down here this censored image
it looks more like a hairy log than it
does a dog
and we hope that the similarity between
these two images will take a pretty big
hit
with this censoring so here we can see
that uh the similarity really drops to
something like 40 percent
when you censor these these top 20 of
the pixels
so this gives us a kind of formal way to
understand
the importance of the pixels that these
different interpretability methods are
selecting
namely that if we remove the top 20
of the pixels it should have the largest
effect on the image similarity
so by doing this for hundreds of
different matches we're able to kind of
get a rough sense of
the quality of each one of these induced
image interpretability methods so we can
see that the methods like kernel shaft
and partition shaft
actually do perform a lot better than
lime and other methods in the literature
and this really is kind of coming from
the formal guarantees that chap provides
so finally i want to take a bit of a
detour to
a different area of thinking about this
algorithm
and the idea comes from the fact that
these k-nearest neighbor data structures
really tell us something non-trivial
about the space that we're applying them
to
in the literature these days k nearest
neighbor data structures can be improved
by using unsupervised learning
techniques
if you split the points in your ball
tree based on k
means clustering or based on splitting
on
hierarchical pca researchers find that
you can perform a lot better than just
splitting using a heuristic
so in some sense the the data structure
that's induced
will perform a lot better if it actually
captures the variance
in your data set so if we
think about it we can use k nearest
neighbor data structures as sort of a
microscope to understand our data set
and understand how our conditions are
scattered throughout our data set
so here i have a visualization of the
metropolitan museum of arts k
nearest neighbor tree and specifically
which
nodes of the tree contain american
artworks
and you can see it's kind of clumpy you
know you have these big splotches of red
where there's no
american artworks next to big splotches
of blue where there's a lot of american
artworks
so we can kind of formalize this notion
where um if we take a look at how many
of these nodes are read
okay don't contain any american artworks
about 41 percent of them don't contain
american artworks
we were to randomly shuffle the labels
to kind of ensure that american art
is homogeneous throughout the space we'd
see that we can only prune 12 percent of
the labels
so in some sense this is measuring the
difference between these two
distributions the difference between
american art
and all the art that exists and
this measurement of the difference
between these two distributions
is is very fine green you know we can
see it visually
we can see where there are no american
artworks and where there's a plethora of
american artworks and this
is a very useful tool in particular
this has very useful applications to
generative adversarial networks
and as a brief introduction to
generative adversarial networks these
are a class of algorithm
that are designed to dream up fake data
more precisely to sample from
complicated probability distributions
like the probability distribution over
faces so the way that these methods work
is that there are two parts a generator
and a discriminator
and the generator's job is to dream up
new faces
and the discriminator's job is to tell
the difference between
fake faces and real faces these two
algorithms battle against each other
for many many hours and eventually the
generator gets so good at creating faces
that they're almost
indistinguishable from real human faces
so these are two examples from a paper
called progressive growing of gans for
improved quality stability and
variation and was really one of the
first scans to achieve
almost indistinguishability on these
generated faces
but um as many researchers have found
throughout the
years that gans can produce really
stunning faces
but these faces tend to have systematic
biases
they don't properly account for all of
the variation in the data set
you know people find that these faces
tend to be
really aligned with the majority class
of the data set
so what we wanted to do was see if this
kind of k nearest neighbor data
structure can tell us a little bit more
about
where these algorithms fail where
they're actually avoiding in the data
set
so as a brief explanation
of the experimental setup we form a data
set
based on the training data of one of
these generative adversarial networks
data set called celeb ahq this is just a
bunch of pictures of
various different celebrities and we
also take its outputs
all these fake dreamed up celebrities
that the algorithm is producing
so we'll color them in the tree blue
nodes tend to have
a large amount of algorithm outputs
and red nodes tend to just contain the
real data don't really have any
close matches from the algorithm so we
can actually perform a little hypothesis
testing and find the nodes that are most
statistically
significant and we see that there's a
huge amount of structure there's this
giant kind of blue
rib that runs down one side this is an
area where the gan
is really good at creating images that
look like real data
but everywhere else there's huge areas
of red which means that this scan is
systematically under sampling
this particular region of the data and
if we just look at some of these areas
where the gan
is systematically undersampling the data
we find some really stunning results
so here i've taken a few representative
examples from
one particular node with a high
discrepancy
and we can see that all of the people in
there one are male and two
they're all have microphones and i've
just shown four examples but literally
every single example on this node had a
microphone in it
and if we look at the kinds of samples
that are pulled from the gan that are
close to these these photos of
microphones
they can't even draw a microphone and
they're also have significant visual
artifacts
so it kind of shows that gann is really
struggling to hallucinate these
microphones it's something that
isn't in a lot of the data and is kind
of hard if it's just used to drawing
faces
likewise uh one of the other nodes that
we found that had a lot of high
discrepancy
had a ton of samples with cowboy hats so
these big brimmed hats on
and when we look at the representative
fakes from this particular node
we see that they really struggle to
generate the hat and they have the again
these really significant visual
artifacts that make the faces look
downright terrifying so this particular
method
allows you to find these areas where the
gan
is is really generating bad
images so that you can kind of better
diagnose and understand
where your gan is particularly failing
and this has kind of become
an interesting topic in ai fairness
where you want to make sure that the gan
is pretty good at generating everything
not just the majority class so in
summary
we've seen how conditional image
retrieval methods
can do things like find cross-cultural
connections in the metropolitan museum
of art
and also help us diagnose biases in
generative image networks so with that
i thank you all for listening and want
to give some thanks to my advisor
william freeman for all of his help and
comments
our great mit externs who worked for a
month
to create the website aka.ms mosaic
the nerd garage team who helped organize
this effort
and um connect us with the externs and
to scott lumberg
chris hoder anand lay al and ryan
for all their help throughout the
project and for getting us in touch
with the met and the reichs museum who
graciously open source their collections
so that this work and a variety of other
different technological work in the
space of the arts is possible
hi everyone this is mark hamilton thank
you very much for watching and
this starts the portion of the talk
that's kind of the live q a
so you guys have been asking some
amazing questions throughout this
and we really appreciate that and so
we'll be kind of going through some of
the
questions that we feel might be most
helpful to everyone in the call
and answering them with a little more
detail so one of the first
questions that i want to touch upon is
one that a lot of different people asked
in various different
formulations in the chat which was
um you know can this approach be applied
to
different domains biomedical images
satellite images
3d images videos
and i think the short answer is yes as
long as you have
a good way to featurize your data
you know it doesn't really matter what
kind of data you use
so long as your features are and the
distance between the features
is representative of what you would like
in our case we wanted to make sure that
the distance between the features really
corresponded to
high-level visual similarity
and when you use features where the
distance corresponds to
something meaningful the algorithm
becomes meaningful as a result
and so another great question that is in
longness vein was
can you use this approach in
could you trade off between visual
similarity
and something else like subject matter
or texture
or color
so the shorter answer is yes that when
you use a different set of features that
maybe prioritizes something like
patterns or style or color your
resulting matches will prioritize that
as well
so one explicit example that we kind of
mentioned in the paper is that
if instead of using the features from
resnet50
if you use the features from a style
transfer network
like adaptive instance normalization
what you'd find is an algorithm that
threw away the contents and really just
cared for
stylistic visual analogies so
there's a lot of different ways you can
kind of manipulate this problem to get
at
what you want another
great question that got brought up was
whether this approach could be
applicable in the streaming scenario
now while this work didn't explicitly
target
the streaming scenario there are a lot
of works that do
aim to build up nearest neighbor trees
in the streaming scenario and so you
could imagine
because this approach really applies to
any nearest neighbor
tree that you build you can imagine
keeping track
of the the information in the
elasticsearch index
as you change the information in your
tree
so it would involve a few modifications
and tweaks but i think fundamentally
this kind of approach as part is
possible and if you want more
information you can definitely feel free
to reach out to us
ah another great question was really
asking to clarify
the interplay between the two different
kinds of indexing methods
that we use namely the elasticsearch
inverted index
and the ball tree from ka nearest
neighbors
so dive into a little bit about
what the interplay is is that we're not
just using one or the other
we're using a hybrid data structure that
uses the the ball tree or the k
nearest neighbor tree to organize the
spatial information
and uses elastic search to organize the
conditional information and it's not
just using
both of these indexes at the same time
elastic searches
documents are actually nodes
of the ball tree so there's this kind of
uh they need to be
plumbed together in the correct way
and what this allows you to do is really
quickly prune
the k nearest neighbor tree to fit your
particular
logical query that you have give to
elasticsearch
so it kind of tethers these two
algorithms together and allows you to
get sort of the best of both
worlds
also had a few questions that were
really
tend to follow the theme of what about
other
kinds of similar
model interpretability methods so one
question
was about
model activation visualization or
saliency maps
and another question was about layer
wise relevance propagation
and deep lift so these three things are
all different
kinds of ways to interpret classifiers
or regressors
and could be applied to interpret
similarity networks
by doing the same kind of transformation
that we applied to bring
lime and chap into the similarity
network
interpretation space so what i mean more
specifically is that you
kind of take your um
you take your similarity network and you
do a transformation to make it look like
a classifier
it spits out a similarity score it takes
in a single image and compares it to
your result image with this you can
apply all the tools from
the model explainability literature like
activation
um visualization or layer wise
uh relevance propagation or deep lift
and i should also mention that um shap
kind of generalizes some of these
approaches so i'm pretty sure it
generalizes deep
lift and others as
particular more specifically deep lift
is a particular approximation
approximation
to additive shapely values and that
original
additive shapely value paper goes on to
say that additive shapely values are
kind of
the the unique
ways to interpret your model
in such a way that it has a lot of
mathematical guarantees
so it's a very interesting space there
there's a lot of interplay and a lot of
different methods that all seem to be
getting at the same kind of idea
but through various different ways and
so it's exciting to be able to work with
all of them at the same time
look at some of the other questions now
ah this is a great one um is there a way
we can improve the bad
images generated by the generator which
were trained by the image of people's
wearing hats or images having
microphones along with the face
so this question really aims to get at
now that we know that there are bad
images in the collection is that the
is particularly bad at creating certain
areas of the collection can we fix it
and um
i think that yes as the short answer is
that
you know you can imagine a whole
different barrage of different ways to
intervene to fix these
issues and one of my colleagues at mit
david dao
has a nice paper where he even shows
that just
adding in random conditions to a network
can improve its performance on these
particular
areas so that's kind of one way that you
can fix this is that
if you have knowledge that there are
microphones or particular aspects that
the algorithm is not getting
correct you can consider making a
conditional
gan and the mere fact that you give the
condition
kind of forces the gan not to be able to
wriggle out
of generating these images it kind of
says no you have to generate an image
with a microphone
and the discriminator knows that in
these conditional games
it knows what the conditional
information is so it knows that i should
be looking for a microphone and if you
don't make a microphone
then you're not a very good generator so
adding conditional information
can be one way to improve the
performance of gans
really more broadly i think in the
spirit of gans
at any way you can discriminate the real
data from the fake data
is theoretically a signal that you can
use to train the method
so the more ways that we can figure out
how
images that are generated are different
from
images that are real um the
the more kind of modes of signal the
discriminator could use in learning for
future algorithms
is okay great um here's here's another
great question is there a way to get the
conditional network working when we
don't have ground truth
labels can features be learned
like in recommender systems can we learn
features of images of movies and users
this is a really great leading question
and again the short answer is yes
definitely
there are a wide variety of methods you
can use
to learn features for data that don't
require any labels at all
i posted one answer that kind of
answered a similar question in this
realm
pointed uh the the asker to sim clr
which is a recent paper by jeff hinton's
group that
beat even supervised pre-training so
it's even better than using the labels
in imagenet
so what this approach does is you the
the basic idea
is that you can take any image data set
and learn to understand it
without labels by playing different
kinds of games
with the images so you can randomly flip
the image
and tell the algorithm to predict
whether you flipped it or not
or randomly change the color or randomly
make it brighter or darker and ask the
algorithm to determine what
went wrong with the image what you did
to it
or even to push these images with
similar transformations together and
with
different transformations far apart so
uh what these various different kinds of
approaches
allow you to do is effectively learn
really good features that
correspond to high level similarity like
the resonant 50 features
but without any labels that you could
apply this directly to your satellite
images
or your biomedical data or whatever
crazy data set you have that doesn't
necessarily have labels
and also on this this ascarimention
recommender systems and this is
a really good other way to get features
that you don't need to just get features
from one of these vision networks or
a game you can also get features from
really anywhere that they crop up in
machine learning
so recommender systems are particularly
good
area where these low dimensional
features that represent users and items
crop up quite naturally
and so you could consider
exploring that
here's a good question is the kd tree
method similar to annoy
and f-a-i-s-s yes
annoy and if i'm not quite sure about
fais but annoying specifically
is um an ensemble of trees approach so
it's an approximate nearest neighbor
method it's very fast
and it uses an ensemble of uh
random projection trees which are a
slight variant of kd
trees to um store the data and basically
it traverses these trees in parallel
and it doesn't exhaustively search for
the closest match it just finds a good
match
um after a little round of exploring the
tree
so in the future we hope to integrate
with annoy and if anyone knows uh
you know if anyone's familiar with
coding in annoying we'd love to
you know help them add this to annoy
because it's certainly one that we use a
lot
over here
and i think there's a follow-up about
f-a-i-s-s and
so i guess specifically um
the information that you the information
that
you might want to ask when approaching a
new nearest neighbor method is
there's three main types of nearest
neighbor methods
there's hashing based there's tree based
and there's graph based and so our
research applies mainly to tree-based
methods
and these other two approaches graph
based and hashing based
are a little bit harder to to move into
this regime although we won't say
impossible because who knows what future
research can hold
so i think that the applicability of
this to
fais would really depend on
is fa iss tree based or is it graph or
hash based
if it's tree based then you could
imagine integrating this with that
system
one other interesting question that
might be good to discuss is that
someone asked if we were using euclidean
distance
and um the the answer is no
we don't use euclidean distance and um
it's for a particularly interesting
reason in that euclidean distance is
particularly
bad in high dimensional spaces that
euclidean distance is not very robust
to uh in high dimensional spaces it
really
changes its fundamental way of working
it's completely dominated by outliers
and things like this
whereas cosine distance or angular
distance basically the angle between
two points is much more robust in higher
dimensional space
and this angular distance is very
related to the dot product
between vectors so the angular distance
more formally is the dot product between
two normalized vectors
and researchers find that this angular
distance is just much more robust in
higher dimensional spaces and really
captures the geometry a lot better
than euclidean distance so there's a few
different
papers about why this is the case and
there's also a few blogs out there if
you
google this topic and have some really
clever visualizations to help you
understand and
really the moral of the story on this
problem and
across a variety of machine learning is
that
high dimensional spaces are very
different than low dimensional space in
ways that are
completely surprising and unintuitive
and one of my favorite examples
of this that someone somewhat related
but um
is that the gaussian the the
bell curve the standard normal
distribution fundamentally changes
in high dimensional space that in low
dimensional space the bell curve looks
like a bell
and you know in one dimensional space
looks like a bell and two dimensions it
looks like a
you know a hill in three dimensions it
looks like a ball
in four dimensions it looks like a four
dimensional ball but in high dimensions
it looks like a thin spherical shell it
fundamentally
changes its shape in a very astounding
way and so
you know this is just one particular
example of how high dimensional space
gives a lot of complexities arise
and also explains why these lower
dimensional features that come out of
these networks tend to perform a lot
better
because they avoid some of the
difficulties in high dimensional space
all right and i guess um you know that
pretty much covers a lot of the main
questions
and for for others who want to learn
about kind of more details you can
definitely check out our paper
in the right hand side in the sidebar
we have a live website that you can go
to to actually play with and explore
this algorithm the code has been open
source so you can check that out as well
and definitely feel free to get in touch
with us my email is on the slides
it's probably not too hard to find me
and thank you all for coming to this
webinar we really appreciate you taking
the time out of your day
and we hope that this was helpful to
your work
in your research and if you want to get
in touch to collaborate or to
recommend other references or use cases
please feel free to do so
you